[Music]
hey cousin today we're making Lomo
saltado a Peruvian inspired steak and
fries stir-fry I'm using two pounds of
round steak that's sliced into thin
pieces I add garlic paste cumin black
pepper soy sauce and some aji amarillo
paste this is on the spicy side and less
is more I add a little oil and I combine
I add the steak into my pan going on
medium heat along with a cup of water
and I let this cook until the liquid
evaporates or about 30 minutes in the
meantime I air fry my French fries these
are freezer section fries that I air Fry
at 400 for 10 minutes if you'd rather
make fresh fries it's your world then I
add two sliced tomatoes I removed the
center jelly you know the seeds and a
red onion I combine into the pan and I
let this cook for three minutes I add
the french fries I turn off the heat
combine and I sprinkle a little cilantro
on top and just like that we have an
easy Lomo saltado enjoy cousin